hello and happy Sunday to people who
were genius enough to subscribe to me
alright so as you may or may not have
heard and if you subscribe to me you
probably have heard because apparently
you like movies entertainment games
things like that there's a trailer to a
game coming out called Dead Island and I
have never gotten so many requests to
talk about one thing everyone's like
dude check out the Dead Island trailer
have you checked out the Dead Island
trailer dude check out the Dead Island
trailer dude Dead Island and it got so
big I was like no way can live up to
this hype I mean the trailers been out
for like two three days it's already
gone viral it has like two million hits
but as of like a day and a half ago I
haven't seen it and my friend was like
dude have you heard about this trailer
to a game called Dead Island and I was
like yes like everyone wants me to talk
about it what is it so we're like I
don't know but let's check it out we
were kind of talking he's not
talking but we were like there's no
way that's gonna live up to the hype all
right let's see some overrated trailer
ISM is gonna be super hyped it's gonna
be awesome and we watched it we were
like that was really good yeah and it is
really good it's no secret that zombies
are taking over vampires it's like the
thing now at least two dudes two chicks
chicks I think still like vampires if
they sparkle dudes we want zombie
apocalypse like I said my zombie then
review we've wanted to happen to fact
we've never gotten emotional about it
and this trailer makes those do that and
I don't want to show you any footage to
the trailer because it'll take away from
it this isn't a review of the trailer
it's really just me advocating that you
should watch it because it's not every
day there's something that becomes so
huge and viral in like two days still
impresses me it was really good this is
how you make a teaser trailer to a game
or even a movie it shows nothing about
gameplay I don't know how the game will
play it could be a first-person shooter
it could be an RPG but the mood is
really good it's like zombies meets
memento yeah you heard that right meets
that song from lost that plays when
people die so if you like any of those
three things watch the Dead Island
trailer so put the link below go check
it out come back here comment let me
know what you think if that game ends up
sucking I think the entire Internet's
gonna rise up and burn a studio to the
ground so dudes who are making the game
don't let it suck and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more